interpellé une cinquantaine de fois par
la police comme cette fois en avril 2019
c'est la dernière fois
pourriez-vous fermer la personne
il trouve que le jugement de la Cour
supérieure est un premier pas dans la
bonne direction je pense que les
policiers peuvent bien faire leur
travail sans avoir à profilé parce que
les policiers sont justement là pour
protéger servir citoyens des groupes
minoritaires ont droit cette même
protection dans son jugement de 170
pages le juge Michel lierjo conclut que
le profilage racial existe bel et bien
ce n'est pas une abstraction construite
en laboratoire ce n'est pas une vue de
l'esprit c'est une réalité qui se
manifeste en particulier auprès des
conducteurs noirs de véhicules
automobiles même si la pratique était
déjà encadrée dans certains corps de
police comme le SPVM pour plusieurs
avocats la décision est historique il
pourrait faire jurisprudence du pays ce
jugement là aujourd'hui vient d'abord
souligner l'existence du profilage
racial mais également le fait que ce
type de pratique le doit cesser les
policiers du Québec devront renoncer
aussi au barrage routier pour
intercepter de potentiels conducteurs en
état débriété on a beaucoup amélioré
bilan au cours des 20 30 dernières
années et on pense qu'une des façons
d'améliorer bilan c'est de permettre à
nous pas ici de vérifier l'état de
conduite la mairie de Montréal Valérie
plante dit accueillir favorablement le
jugement il n'y a pas de place dans la
société pour le profilage social et
racial alors c'est un jugement qu'on
conserve qui est qui est le bon alors
que le Premier ministre François Legault
lui aimait quelques réserves écoutez
c'est un jugement qui est long qui doit
être analysé par contre quand on parle
d'interpellation aléatoire ben il faut
comprendre qu'il faut laisser les
policiers faire leur travail les
policiers du Québec auront un de six
mois pour se conformer aux nouvelles
directives de la course supérieure mais
un appel de la décision pourrait bien
changer la donne ici Gabriel pro
Radio-Canada Montréal